well my reaction is just I don't really
want to listen to a spiritual advisor I
mean that's ridiculous I think they've
actually made a graceful decision here
we don't know the extent to which they
were forced into it by the palace but I
think this is the absolutely the right
decision uh Prince Harry needs to come
in and be seen to be there I think
you'll get the hell out pretty quickly
she would have been a huge distraction
doubtless there would have been booing
it would have been very uncomfortable
for the rest of the royal family so I
think it was the right decision I don't
know why you're making that funny face
oh because we're British we don't boo
people
[Laughter]
spiritual Guru or advice I mean
Californians
the absurdity of the lady I mean it's
just ridiculous she tries to sort of
infer that she's she understands
Ordinary People and she she cares about
things and she's got a spiritual Guru